is that a glock in your pocket no ryan
reynolds jumps into the world of video
games in free guy as the lovable
sentient npc guy who lives inside the
video game free city from its flashy cgi
creative decisions and exciting cameos
there's lots to enjoy so it's time to
whip out those gamer glasses and look at
some of the behind the scenes secrets
around free guy i'm gonna be the great
guy
okay
one of the most interesting aspects
about free guy is the fact that it's set
in two different worlds the virtual free
city and of course the real world for
inspiration on the creation of free city
director sean levy looked to the popular
video game franchise grand theft auto
wanting to portray the game as a more
dangerous place where experiencing 8 to
16 robberies daily is normal for a bank
teller and threatening scenarios lurk in
every corner meanwhile levy and dp
george richmond wanted to make the look
between the two worlds noticeable
writing script bibles for how each
setting would be filmed the biggest game
influences were gta and fortnite you may
be surprised to learn that the scene
where free guy first puts on the gamer
glasses and sees his city for what it
really is used a lot of practical
effects
everything aside from the apache
helicopter crashing into the building
was actually done practically including
the zipline levy revealed that it took
11 takes until they felt they had it
right that was really happening and
these actors and rel had to play it
completely straight
free guy surely isn't without plenty of
cgi but sean levy wanted to make sure
that the production could also use
practical effects whenever necessary one
of the recurring gags in the film
following a man literally on fire
running into the streets was actually
done practically this did lead to some
stressful moments with levy revealing
that guy has to be lit on fire to the
second put out within a certain number
of seconds or it gets very dangerous
despite the pressure levy felt it was
all worth it in the end no ryan reynolds
did not get shredded to take on the role
of blue shirt guy's shredded double
ganger dude in fact dude's stand-in on
set was professional bodybuilder aaron w
reed reed has been used to working as an
extra on television but free guy marks
his first role in a major motion picture
reynolds face was later superimposed on
to read to create the disturbing
look-alike yo my free city bros antoine
here free guy's main antagonist is
played by oscar winner taika ytt who
also co-starred with reynolds in green
lantern but both actors would like you
to forget about that you did green
lantern it was definitely green line
right
the cast and crew were abuzz about ytt
and claimed that even when he wasn't on
set his presence was always felt jody
comer claimed that you could leave the
camera rolling for 15 minutes and that
guy would not stop levy who worked with
comedy legends from the likes of the
late robin williams as well as ricky
gervais has said that ytt is in the
ranks of both who's the best martial
artist in the whole wide world
steven sequoia
no ryan reynolds movie is complete
without lots of pop culture references
and free guys gaming theme led to many
opportunities for the creative team if
you're worried that all the little
references will overtake the story
reynolds assured fans saying i don't
think easter eggs are a storytelling
pillar but i do think that easter eggs
are something that audiences love and i
love and appreciate so the movie will be
riddled with easter eggs since free guy
is a 20th century studios film which is
in turn owned by disney it gave the
filmmakers the opportunity to throw in
some marvel and star wars related easter
eggs including appearances of characters
like the hulk as well as the use of
lightsabers several surprises in free
guide
unlike the other video game themed movie
ready player one which used cgi to show
the characters avatars free guy has
actual actors in the roles of free
cities inhabitants instead of pulling
from grand theft auto sean levy was
inspired by fortnite for the character
designs including utkarsh and budkar's
mousers in-game bunny suit levy
suggested that this decision will also
add to the overall comedy of the film
excuse me it reminded me that sometimes
the best comedy comes out of something
that doesn't make sense
jody comer was already used to playing
in more physical roles having played the
cold psychotic yet sexy villanelle in
killing eve but the one aspect of her
character she wasn't prepared for was
gaming comer found herself playing
several different video games like grand
theft auto which she found a tad too
stressful comer did find comfort in
playing marvel's spider-man claiming
that it felt more carefree the idea of
playing the two characters was something
i found really attractive
ryan reynolds wasn't the only one who
was tasked with playing two different
characters jody comer had an even bigger
challenge playing two very different
versions of the same character millie
and her digital persona molotov girl to
differentiate between the two versions
of the same character comer used
differing accents as well as having to
apply a wig when playing the femme
fatale molotov girl
one thing comer never had to do was play
both the roles on the same day i think
they were pretty um strategic free guy
was originally set to hit theaters in
july of 2020 but like many other movies
was forced to be delayed because of the
pandemic the lengthy delay turned out to
be a blessing in disguise for levy and
crew while initially the creative team
set a limit to the amount of easter eggs
that were in the film levy along with
production designer ethan taubman made
the decision to add more to the movies
so free city could feel more populated
one of the easter eggs that was added in
post was the tank from the popular video
game franchise halo that can be seen
patrolling the streets
fans of reynolds are used to seeing the
a-list star tackle roles that much like
deadpool are full of snark and are
mean-spirited free guy was a gear change
for reynolds so this is slightly new for
me there's something really wonderful
about playing a character who's kind of
naive and innocent there are several
surprise
cameos free guy features plenty of
cameos from all different kinds of movie
stars and even influencers levy
recruited multiple popular online
streamers to appear in the film from the
likes of ninja pokemon and even
jacksepticeye many of them were really
appreciative of the experience and would
even do it again if they had the chance
pokemon especially loved being able to
have a second take at her scenes when
you're streaming you gotta say it right
the first time they might be clipped out
of context you might be in some trouble
the beloved late host of jeopardy alex
trebek is one of the many cameos in free
guy reynolds who's no stranger to
jeopardy serving as a contributor and
guest in several episodes simply asked
trebek to make a cameo we asked him and
he said yes and i was just so thrilled
that he's there immortalized up on on
the screen free guy begins with a
bombastic one-take shot that director
sean levy and his team have been
planning for over a year and a half i
always wanted the movie to start with an
opening warner introduces us to the
crazy rules of this kind of surreal
world joe kiri who plays keys in the
film has actually worked with sean levy
before several times in fact we all know
kiri from his role as steve in stranger
things but you may not have known that
levy has actually been heavily involved
in the hit sci-fi series i just trust
him you know as a director and that's i
think the most important thing is just
faith that they're going to create you
know the vision that's in their head
free guy is certainly one wild ride it's
abundantly clear just how passionate the
cast and crew were when making the
action comedy from unexpected cameos to
crazy characters there's a reason why
the film has attracted so many fans what
was your favorite moment from free guy
you